[Music]
i really think my strategy was to change
as the game changes and to be dynamic
the game is always changing your friends
are going to go home you have to
reinvent yourself when your alliance or
the dynamic in the game changes
i would say accomplished as someone who
wins throughout the season is able to
win many competitions whether they're
vetoes or hoh where the whole house
knows they're a threat but they're able
to use competitions to help circumvent
that threat you never know what the
comps are going to be i say being
physically fit may help but it looks
like on my season it didn't do much for
me it was actually my mental my memory
is what ended up really getting me
through that game
congratulations you are the final hoh
for season 9.
[Music]
you have to play the game that best fits
you and sometimes
you can be a floater just based on your
personality type and based on the other
personality types in the house i have a
lot of respect for it but
only if it's a strategy if you just
floated because
you're just hanging out
that's what i don't respect if it's a
purposeful strategy and you can
articulate that that was your strategy
then yeah i have so much respect for it
[Applause]
my advice to someone in a showmance
don't be in one ty's a very flirty guy
i just know that i catch feelings very
easily keep it as more of a flirt match
or have it appear as a flirtmats the
rest of the house guest because once
you're in a showmance you're locked in
[Music]